[MUSIC PLAYING]
NOAM SHAZEER: Hi.
My name is Noam Shazeer.
I'm going to tell you
about Mesh-TensorFlow,
which is a system we built for
training giant models on TPU
pods.
So we're going to talk
about data-parallelism
and model-parallelism,
and also about why
I want to train giant
models and why we need
model parallelism to do it.
Then I'll tell you about
the Mesh-TensorFlow system.
So first data-parallelism--
this is how, roughly, everybody
trains neural networks if you
have distributed hardware.
This is what we use
on TPU pods at Google.
And generally, you put your
entire model on every device,
split up the training batch
into a lot of little trunks,
one on each device.
Run it.
Then add up all the
gradients on the parameters
across all the devices
and do your update.
This works really well.
The communication is fast
on all kinds of networks,
on lots of different types
of networks, in fact.
So this is roughly
what everyone's doing.
The great things about
it are it's universal.
You can use any
model architecture.
It's fast to compile because
you're writing a SPMD code.
You're writing code for
what one device is doing,
and then you can
compile it and send it
to every device which
is using the same code.
And you get roughly
full utilization
because every device is
doing roughly the same thing.
So if they're all
similar, then nobody
is waiting for anybody else.
And the communication is fast.
The only problem is that you
cannot train giant models.
Because your entire model
has to fit on every device.
So why do I want to
train giant models?
Well, I like working
on language modeling.
There are lots of important
applications, machine
translation, question answering,
dialogue, sentimental analysis,
lots of interesting things
to do with language.
And we find that quality
improves with model size.
So a bigger model tends to
know more about the world,
understand things
better, and give you
overall better results.
There's plenty of data out
there to train a giant model.
Just download the text of the
web, common crawl, whatever,
and you've got
billions to trillions
of words of training data.
And in fact, you can
train one big model
and then fine tune it to do
lots of different things.
There's been a lot of research--
OpenAI, and BERT at Google on
transfer learning and language.
So it's a great candidate
for building giant models.
Now, as an example, I trained
a transformer language model
with roughly 100
million parameters
on the text of Wikipedia.
The Abraham Lincoln
article was in the dev set,
in the held out set, and I told
it to generate a random Abraham
Lincoln article.
And it looks
roughly grammatical.
It remembers somehow
that he's a politician,
American politician.
There's plenty it doesn't
know about the world,
like who Abraham Lincoln
was, or that America
doesn't have a prime minister,
and lots of other stuff.
But if you make
the similar model,
just bigger, here's with five
billion parameters instead
of 100 million.
And now it seems to have picked
up a lot more about Abraham
Lincoln.
Roughly half of that
stuff is correct.
But you know--
[LAUGHTER]
--mostly it's fake news.
But there are more important
applications out there
than generating fake news.
But this is just a
nice demonstration
that model size is important.
What would a model look like
with a trillion parameters?
We have not done that yet.
But we hope to do that soon.
OK.
So if all the parameters
will not fit on one core,
we need to do something called
model-parallelism, which
means that we're
splitting the model itself
between different devices.
And that should let us
train really large models,
and it should also be very
good for inference latency,
because now the
computation for one example
can be split across
multiple devices.
The problem is it's
very tricky to design
these kinds of algorithms.
How do people tend to do it now?
Well, you use device placement.
You say this operation
is going on this device.
This operation is
going on that device.
TensorFlow makes
it easy to do that.
Still, it's tricky to design
an efficient algorithm.
And you end up
with a giant graph,
if you're generating
enough operations
to go on 2,000 different cores.
Here's an example of
some model-parallelism
by device placement from
Google Neural Multimachine
Translation.
They had eight LSTMs,
which they distributed
across eight different GPUs.
The softmax layer they
put somewhere else.
And you need some kind
of interesting pipelining
to keep all the GPUs busy.
It works, but a lot of work to
get this thing to work right.
Now we're going to take a
totally different approach,
which is going to be
inspired by what works well
about synchronous
data-parallelism.
So we will have every processor
involved in every operation.
We're going to use SPMD
style programming, where
you'll have the same
program on every device.
And it's going to use collective
communication, like allreduce,
just like data-parallelism.
And our library for doing this
is called Mesh-TensorFlow.
We should be able to
implement data-parallelism,
model-parallelism.
We should be able to split--
in different dimensions,
like split an image or video
spatially or any sorts of
combinations of these things.
And we're targeting
hardware where
you have a homogeneous
set of similar processors,
ideally well-connected
like a TPU pod.
We've got these two dimensional
supercomputers at Google
that we've been using.
And you're going to view
your set of processors
as an n-dimensional mesh.
It doesn't have to correspond to
a physical n-dimensional mesh.
You could view a two
dimensional mesh of processors
as a one dimensional mesh.
But, of course, performance will
depend on those considerations.
So how does this all work?
Well, in data-parallelism,
you can view it
as splitting the batch dimension
of the computation across all
your processors.
So any tensor that
has a batch dimension
is going to be split across
all of the processors.
And any tensor that does not
have a batch dimension, meaning
the parameters, gets
fully replicated.
Now we're going to
do the same thing,
but for model-parallelism,
we will choose
different dimensions to split.
So maybe dimensions representing
the sizes of hidden layers--
and we will decide to
split those dimensions
across the set of processors.
And the communication
will happen--
usually, an operation will
not involve communication.
But some operations will involve
collective communication,
like all reduce--
particularly, when you're
reducing out split dimensions.
And this is going to be
somewhat similar to how
things work in synchronous
data-parallelism.
So let's do an example, a simple
three layer neural network.
Input layer X, hidden
layer H, output layer
Y, and we have two
weight matrices,
W and V. The
data-parallel way to do
this is that we are going to
split anything with a batch
dimension, meaning the
activations X, H, and Y.
So all of those tensors are
split evenly across processors.
And each tensor that does
not have a batch dimension, W
and V, will be replicated
across every processor.
So here it's showing what
Processor 0 is doing,
what Processor 1 is doing.
They're both doing
something roughly similar,
except they have different
halves of the activation.
You don't see any communication
in the forwards pass.
But if you were to see the
backwards pass where you're
computing the
parameter gradients,
you would see some matmuls
where the split dimension b gets
reduced out, and there would
be some all reduces in there.
So we're going to now,
instead of splitting V,
let's split the size of the
hidden layer, dimension H.
So we do that.
And now X and Y, the input and
output, are fully replicated.
Because they do not
have an H dimension.
But the hidden layer
H is split because it
does have an H dimension.
And the parameter
matrices, W and V,
also have an H dimension.
So they're split.
So again, you have a
parallel-computation on the two
processors, and you see an
all reduced communication
when you're computing Y
because we're reducing out
the split dimension H.
We didn't have to
split H. Instead,
we could have split V, which
is the dimension of X and Y.
So in that case, you would have
a different pattern of which
tensors are split and
which ones are replicated.
And you'd have communication
in different places.
And if you want to
get really fancy,
let's do data-parallelism and
model-parallelism at once.
We're going to
split dimension b,
the batch across one axis of our
two dimensional supercomputer.
And we're going to
split the hidden layer
H across the other axis
of our mesh of processors.
So now, we have different
sensors being either split
in one dimension and
replicated in the other,
or since tensor H has
both of those dimensions,
it ends up piled among
all the processors.
And there are going
to be all reduced
communications in there, but
not across all the processors.
They'll be partitioned
all reduces just
across rows or just
across columns.
So the general case is give all
of the tensor dimensions names.
And we define the layout
of the communication
as a map from tensor
dimensions to mesh dimensions,
saying which tensor
dimensions get split
across which mesh dimensions.
For example, in
the previous slide
we had the batch
tensor dimensions
split across processor rows,
and the hidden size dimensions
split across processor columns.
We did this to our transformer,
machine translation
slash language
model, and here are
the layouts we used
for data-parallelism,
model-parallelism and
combined parallelism for that.
For the model-parallelism,
it works
to split the size
of the vocabulary,
the size of the feed
forward hidden layer,
and the number of
attention heads.
And if you do that,
you end up splitting up
all of your
communication very nicely
and get a nice model
parallel algorithm.
And that can also be combined
with data-parallelism
by splitting the batch
across the other dimension
of the supercomputer.
Now, picking a good layout
is, for now, something
that you need a
well-trained human to do.
You need to make sure that all
of your expensive operations
are split.
You're not allowed to split two
dimensions of the same tensor
across different
dimensions of the mesh.
And depending on what
dimensions you chop up,
it may result in more
or less communication.
So example, data-parallelism--
you'd like the batch to be big.
Otherwise, you're going to
get a lot of communication.
Similarly, if you're
splitting up a hidden layer,
you might want that
layer to be really big.
So how do you use
Mesh-TensorFlow?
Well, download our
open source repository.
You build a graph in Python,
much like a regular TensorFlow
graph except that you're
using named dimensions.
You define what your
mesh is and how it maps
to your physical processors.
You define your layout of
what gets split across what.
And then Mesh-TensorFlow turns
your mesh TensorFlow graph
into part of a TensorFlow graph.
And you still use
TensorFlow for anything else
you want to use it for, like the
data pipelines and everything
else.
So far we've trained
transformer models on up to five
billion parameters
on entire TPU pods,
getting a good performance
out of the thing.
And these giant
models give state
of the art quality on
some benchmark tasks,
like Latin language modeling
and machine translation,
not surprisingly.
Bigger models are better.
Lots of people are
finding that out.
And in the future, we would
like to try even bigger models,
I think, with some
well-placed sparsity.
We would have the
computation to train models
with a trillion parameters.
We've tried up to a couple
hundred billion for now.
And it runs.
So next thing is to see if we
can get a trillion parameter
model to run and give
us great quality.
And this would be
useful for other things,
like low-latency
inference and situations
where you have giant inputs
that you want to process.
And for now, what works?
Well, we're emitting SPMD code
for TPU, including Cloud TPU.
So this runs nicely
on TPU's pods.
And for CPU and GPU, it's still
emitting the old fashioned
device placement code.
So it runs, but not as scalable.
Everything is out
there on GitHub
and runs with TensorFlow 1--
not yet with TensorFlow 2.
And then, in the future,
we want to use this
for different types of models.
It would be great to automate
the process of choosing
a distributed layout.
Because then you wouldn't need
to know about much TensorFlow
and it would just figure out how
to distribute your computation
for you.
And we welcome contributions
to the open source code
or contact us.
And I'd like to thank
all of my collaborators,
the authors of our paper.
I'd also like to thank the
TensorFlow teams and XLA
team for a lot of
technical support
and help with all of
this, implementing what
we needed to be implemented.
And everything's out there in
our open source repository.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]